Specifically, it's a vector whose entries are all
non-negative real numbers and where the sum of the
entries is equal to one,
so it makes sense to
think about these entries as being probabilities.
Here in this example, there are just two entries because there's just two
classical states of the system we're talking about,
but in general, there could
be any number of entries with the understanding
being that there's one entry for each classical state
of whatever system we're talking about.
We're going to continue
discussing classical information, probability vectors and
so on in just a moment, but first, it's gonna be really helpful
to introduce some notation
for describing vectors known as the Dirac notation.
In fact, this is just the first
part of the Dirac notation.
There are a couple of other
aspects of the Dirac notation that we'll see a little
bit later in the lesson.
This notation is gonna be
quite central to the way that we describe quantum information, so it's essential to
understand how it works,
but fortunately, it's very simple and it really doesn't have
anything specifically to do with quantum information,
so we can introduce it now
in the familiar context of classical information.
As before, we assume that we have a set sigma of
classical states of some system, and let's assume
that we have an ordering
of these classical states, just like how we refer to an
ordering of the binary alphabet
in the previous example. Another way of saying this
is that the elements of sigma are placed in correspondence
with the integer
from one to however many
elements are contained in sigma, which is what this notation right here with two bars around sigma means.
That's the number of
elements in the set sigma.
So there's a first state,
a second state, and so on.
The specific ordering or
correspondence that we choose isn't actually gonna matter all that much.
What's really important is
that we have an ordering and we stick to it.
For many classical state
sets that we'll encounter, there will be a standard ordering just like we have with
the binary alphabet,
and if there isn't a standard ordering, we can just choose one.
But whatever it is, the understanding is that we stick to it.
Now, here's the notation
that's being introduced.
For any choice of a classical
state a from our set sigma, we write this right here, which is read as ket a
to mean the column vector
that has a one in entry corresponding to a and a zero for all other entries.
For example, if we return
to the binary alphabet, which, as you might have guessed, is a very important example
that we'll return to again and again. Then ket zero and ket one are the vectors that are defined right here.
Ket zero is the vector
that has a one in the entry corresponding to the classical state zero, which is the first entry,
and a zero for all other entries, and in this case, there's
only one other entry.
Similarly, ket one is
this vector right here where we have a one in the
entry corresponding to one,
which is the second entry, and a zero for all other entries, which, again, is just one entry.
Here's another example. In this example, we have a
classical state set sigma corresponding to the four suits
in a standard deck of playing cards: clubs, diamonds, hearts, and spades.
In this case, there really isn't a
universally agreed upon ordering of these suits.
For many card games, there is no ordering at all. They're just four different suits and that's all that matters, and there are different card
games that do order these suits
in different ways, but it doesn't really matter.
We can just choose an
ordering like the one that you see right here.
This happens to be alphabetical ordering according to the names of these four suits written in English,
Assuming that we've picked
this particular ordering, then we define these four vectors: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts, and ket spades
as you see right here, and these vectors correspond
to the general description that you see up here.
Given that we've chosen
this particular ordering for these four suits.
We can do the same thing for any classical state
set that we choose.
Keeping in mind that classical
state set always means finite and non empty set.
Vectors of this form are
called standard basis vectors, and it's a very basic fact about vectors that every vector can be
expressed in a unique way
as a linear combination
of standard basis vectors.
For instance, going back to the example from just a moment ago, the probability vector
we saw can be expressed
as you see right here. It's basically just an alternative way of expressing vectors
that's gonna be very handy for several reasons going forward.